stage one of grief denial an assertion
that something said believed alleged etc
is false refusal to believe a doctrine
theory or the like this belief in the
existence or reality of a thing the
refusal to satisfy a claim request
desire etc or the refusal of a person
making it refusal to recognize or
acknowledge a disowning for disavowal
I'm lifeless worthless yet i'm still
blaming this a braveness of brightness
yet I attracts lashes I'm Church less
I'm harmless yet i'm still dangerous I'm
a witness to closing this yet I still
ask myself dot dot dot what is this a
feeling I'm peeling but my heart is
concealing emptiness brokenness let's
find an act and suddenly I'm humorous
heartfelt is unfair but I blame myself
for the cars that my demons dealt the
wars the bars and the Lord's that I
worship the lust that I must convert
into dust while I r us with no trust
everyone's expectations is for me to
readjust climb into my mind look into my
soul do you still see hope because I
feel a hell of a hole see my real
actions and see my real thoughts see my
image darkens I'm suddenly not so hot
I'm whining I'm crying during internal
dying cheer up a peer up so everyone can
just shut the [ __ ] up words of advice
can appear to be nice but if you don't
understand and your advice becomes bland
I'm a failure I'm a loser with the
qualities of a winner so I ask you this
favor please let me reactor so I can
recover why do I bother why do I go
figure what are the factors where are
the answers to the root cause of this
heart that angers I am baffled I am lost
I'm wrangle that of exhaust I make
mistakes and I make them again I'll hit
the brakes but what happens then I crash
and I crash and I don't stop crashing
that backlash like whiplash as my soul
continues thrashing I say I'm sorry but
then I do it again I'll create
boundaries but what happens then I'm a
[ __ ] I'm a mess up hello thoughts can
you please shut the [ __ ] up I'm scared
I'm worried that I'll be all alone I'll
pull you in and push you away because
this is my own comfort zone I'm
brilliant yet I'm ignorant to present
yet on that sent alive on the outside
but dead on the inside honestly is my
policy but also is hypocrisy life gets
rough around the edges but there's no
growth unless you're deep into the
trenches I see the tunnel bow where's
the light is the am blissful or is it
endless spite find me in a world lost in
sorrow by me a soul that is not so
hollow and maybe just maybe I'll recover
by tomorrow I'm good to dish your bites
but I suck at taking my own my
guidelines are precisely and I'm still
stuck in this nightmare of a zone
you